yeah you know for Mountaineers I think
there's always an allure to climbing
Everest whether it's the first time
it's the 11th time it's the highest peak
in the world it's always gonna challenge
us so you know why come to Everest the
11th time I was given this amazing
opportunity to be a part of the first
ascent team and I deliberated long and
hard of why I should be here and I
decided that the challenge was still
there the intrigue being part of this
team and I also decided that I wanted to
try again without supplemental oxygen
that rather fail without oxygen than
succeed using oxygen it's been 22 years
since I've seen Everest from the south
side hasn't gotten any smaller I was
here in 1987 didn't make the summit
doctor 27,000 feet this time I'm back
for a little unfinished business but
some things need to line up the route
the weather my health I'm gonna give it
everything I've got but I'm also gonna
maintain a reasonable margin of safety
the summit super important to me but
even more important is getting back to
my family I'm here as a first ascent
team member last year I was fortunate
enough to summit Mount Everest as a
guide and it just solidified how much I
loved high-altitude mountaineering it's
something I do professionally and I do
it because of the camaraderie with the
people the beautiful places you get to
travel and focusing on a long-term goal
and the challenge of doing that every
single day this year I've decided that
I'm gonna go for a bit of an extra
challenge and I'm gonna attempt to climb
without the use of supplemental oxygen
I'm always asked why Everest or why this
particular trip the reason is as much
why I've chosen my whole life to work
out in the mountains and to work with
people and become a professional
mountain guide Erica during guiding and
we've worked together before we work
together on Denali last year and in fact
helping me to guide last summer on
Denali was Seth waterfall and that's
gonna be helping me on this Mount
Everest climb and together we're gonna
hope to get Erika as high as she
deserves to go
if I were to do this I would be the
youngest American person to do this
although that that's not really why I'm
here to acquire that title I'm just I'm
here to climb with everyone else and try
to make the effort as best possible and
if for some reason I don't make it on
this trip then I have years ahead of me
of climbing that I hope to continue
maybe I'll return someday I'm Seth
Waterfall heading into Everest base camp
to climb Mount Everest with the big guns
Dave Hahn Pete Whittaker and ed Viesturs
can't imagine a better group to be here
with on my first trip to the Himalayas
as you can see walking in to not Everest
one of the most beautiful walks in the
world so it's a I suppose you'd call it
a fringe benefit but it's a pretty nice
one
you